[Musique]
depuis 20 ans l'industrie minière
canadienne n'a cessé de croître et de
cumuler les richesses son terrain de jeu
la planète là où les fils on se trouve
du mali à l'argentine en passant par le
mexique colombie le chili et bien sûr le
canada tous les endroits sont bons pour
sortir des entrailles de la terre de
l'or de l'argent des diamants
l'industrie est florissante mais parfois
au détriment du canada
dans plusieurs endroits de monde
le canada n'est plus un porte drapeau
pour la paix il est devenu l'ennemi
or je mettrai pas du tout de feuille
d'érable sur mon sac à dos quand je l'aï
vu la joie des compagnies minières font
mauvaise réputation au canada selon un
rapport commandé par l'industrie elle
même le tiers des minières qui violent
les droits humains sont canadiennes
les entreprises canadiennes ont fait au
canada une mauvaise réputation au niveau
international et ça c'est ça c'est une
situation qui selon moi est indéniable
les minières canadiennes possèdent
d'énormes territoire à l'étranger en
amérique du sud
des terrains plus grand que la france et
l'espagne ensemble car les minières
canadiennes sont les nouveaux
conquistadors du mexique actuel vient
exploiter nos territoires
sans tenir compte qu'il ya des gens ici
et des dieux sacré pour la vie certaines
compagnies sont accusées de contaminés
ou d'assécher des sources d'eau de
détruire l'environnement de déplacer des
populations contre leur gré l'image du
canada seul à m'être laissé la main du
diable de rester
ce n'est pas tout dans plusieurs pays
on accuse certaines minières canadiennes
de corruption de s'allier à des groupes
criminels et de violer les droits
humains
[Musique]
l'image du canada à l'étranger est
ternie et le pays lui même est en grande
partie responsable de cette situation
car le canada soutient et conseille ses
entreprises
l'ancien premier ministre un peu a même
donné aux minières le titre
d'ambassadrice du pays
le gouvernement canadien a écrit la loi
minière colombienne l'australie vrai
commerciaux les accords de libre-échange
font que les états réduisent leurs
exigences environnementales
de plus lorsqu'il y avait entente
les compagnies peuvent demander des
millions en compensation
alors je ne sais pas comment le système
va y voit lui mais je vois le risque
certains pays fassent comment et
pourquoi en est on arrivé là
bonjour pierre banassac cela fait des
années que je m'intéresse aux compagnies
minières
ici comme avec le plan nord et aussi à
l'étranger
au fil des ans des gens m'ont écrit pour
m'en parler pour dénoncer dès les
premiers appels les sources m'ont
prévenu du danger
c'est un sujet délicat car il ya des
milliards de dollars en jeu et la
violence et la corruption entachent des
pays où se trouvent l'or et l'argent
je voudrais comprendre voir de mes yeux
parler avec les gens sur le terrain pour
découvrir comment fonctionne cette
industrie à l'étranger
[Musique]
il faut tout d'abord elle est au mexique
l'un des principaux partenaires
économiques du canada
[Musique]
le mexique a grugé par les concessions
minières 900 mille kilomètres carrés
l'équivalent de la moitié du québec
c'est trop selon le nouveau président du
pays des concessionnaires par
l'exploitation minet qu'est les
immortels
qualcomm en s'intéressant à des
concessionnaires nana absoluta n'est
acquis non c'est aussi les méthodes
mais celles qui sont là déjà reste le
canada détient la part du lion
il y a plus de 200 minières canadiennes
au mexique
oui deux sens
la sierra norte des puebla une région
agricole mexicaine et le premier arrêt
les montagnes cachent des métaux
précieux et cela a attiré une compagnie
minière canadienne almaden menz
[Musique]
c'est dans la petite ville deepstack à
un territoire autochtone au coeur de la
sierra que nous allons rencontrer notre
guilde et assisté à l'évolution de
l'image des que du canada la loi était
traitée au début quand j'arrivais dans
ces villages on faisait ce que vous êtes
le nouveau au caire où est ce que vous
aimez instituteurs qui a été nommé alors
toujours on passe 50 ha alors j'entre
dans une que je vais dans cette
communauté et si on fait l'assemblée est
quelqu'un désire au canada mais là
travail tue pour la mine
une question qui n'attend qu'une réponse
pierre bocage est un anthropologue
québécois il a passé sa vie à étudier
les communautés mexicaine surtout
autochtone de la sierra dans la région
et les connu et apprécié il a été mon
prof à l'université
c'est une mine d'or de connaissances
[Musique]
c'est dans ce mini cibles dans gaza
comme un site là car entreprises
canadiennes à découvrir à peu près
depuis l'arrivée d'almaden la population
est divisée
les commerçants sont pour d'autres
espèrent des emplois mais la majorité
des paysans et contres pour eux l'eau
est sacrée la concession d'almaden est à
2000 mètres d'altitude a hautement dans
l'eau c'est la grande affaire
donc y'a bon on compte sur la pluie ici
ils tombent entre 600 et 900 mm mais ça
c'est pendant quatre mois de mai à
septembre
ensuite n'y a pas une goutte d'eau qui
tombent à la rue bois à la et c'est long
c'est le point central
[Musique]
r nous amène rencontrer des villageois
cela commence toujours par un repas à sa
table francesca a invité des femmes qui
se mobilisent contre la minière
canadienne
la discussion tourne rapidement sur le
fait que les gens manquent d'eau l'on
disparaît nous distille à partir des
locaux nous avions ici une source d'eau
naturelle violent mais la compagnie a
fait un forage et depuis l'eau a été
déviée
sa production d'ail à sécher sur pied
toute une perte pour elvia 80% ses
revenus se sont envolés calcule-t-elle
et pourtant au début elle n'était pas
contre la manière son fils a même
travaillé pour les canadiens et à sa
bière oui voyez une goutte qui tombe
elle vient compte maintenant sur l'eau
de l'aqueduc qui ne lui parvient qu'un
jour sur 3 la source
elle est arrivée
et c'est dans un endroit où l'hôte et
que sa part à les paysages d'une source
sûre la terre c'est de l'or en barre
les gens affectés considère la minière
responsable qu'elle en soit 300 ans mais
je voudrais dire au canada que nous
sommes mexicaine et que nous ne voulons
pas que les entreprises canadiennes
viennent détruire notre territoire et
territoriaux
la révolte gronde
même les pouvoirs de la vierge de
guadalupe patronne du mexique sont
sollicités pour mettre la minière
canadienne dehors
même si elles madone n'a pas encore
sorti une seule pépite d'or de sa mine
elle cherche de l'eau car cela prendra
beaucoup d'eau pour extraire le précieux
métal
et juste cela sans barbe déjà la vie des
communautés
on veut prouver que c'est vrai et on
m'amène voir les forages
l'eau est sorti angers jusqu'à 15 mètres
de hauteur
cela fait dix ans la compagnie a colmaté
mélo fut encore l'eau d'ici 20 vers
santa maría faisait que le sous sol ici
c'est un fromage de gruyère
c'est un sol calcaire avec des grottes m
de l'eau qui vient de la haute montagne
qui vient qui circulent plus une
direction ou dans l'autre et de ti
modifier quelque chose tu modifies tôt
alejandro nous amène au coeur de la
concession
là où il ya le plus d'or enfant du pays
il est devenu professeur à l'université
il veut nous montrer parce que les
paysans qui arpentent la montagne ont
découvert regardez sur les bandes de 10
puis il y à du ciment neuf avec de
nouvelles inscriptions pour masquer les
anciennes
ils savent que le sujet le plus délicat
pour la population c'est l'eau on a
démontré avec les données fournies par
la compagnie même que ce qu'elle dit est
complètement faux avec ses propres
chiffres
nous avons calculé que la compagnie aura
besoin de deux fois plus d'eau que ce
que consomment les 120 communautés six
est obèse
le ministère de l'environnement du
mexique enquêté il écrit qu'il doute des
données fournies par la compagnie sur
l'endroit et la profondeur des forages
il veut refuse donc l'autorisation
d'aller de l'avant
juste en face de la compagnie on a
rencontré l'inspecteur de police
le des grands défenseurs du projet
canadien ça va créer de l'emploi le
développement et comme l'entreprise va
payer plus d'impôts si pas lesté
bénéfices au santa maria village et tout
l'état vont bénéficier
c'est la première compagnie minière de
la région est allemand les paysans ont
emmené le gouvernement en justice à
propos de cette manne et d'autres
affirmant qu'ils sont autochtones et que
leurs droits n'étaient pas respectés et
cela a été reconnu à la cour la loi
minière du pays a été déclaré illégal
conséquence finale les travaux d'un adn
sont suspendus
forage douteux problèmes d'eau des
enjeux dont j'aurais aimé discuter avec
les représentants d'almaden sur place
mais lors de notre passage
il n'était pas là
[Musique]
j'ai demandé une entrevue au pdg de la
compagnie
il a choisi de me répondre par écrit
selon lui la compagnie peut poursuivre
l'exploration puisque le jugement était
porté en appel
quant à la question de l'eau il est sûr
que les travaux ont été faits en
conformité à la loi et que la compagnie
n'a pas reçu d'amendé almaden en est
encore au stade de l'exploration ici
mais les paysans sont informés ils
savent très bien ce qui est arrivé aux
territoires
ailleurs dans le pays
[Musique]
le guerrero est connu pour les plages
d'acapulco li milliers de québécois qui
se prélassent dans ce panorama de
vacances ne doute pas qu'ils masquent
une région dangereuse
une vingtaine de groupes criminels se
disputent le territoire assassinats
viols fosses communes font partie de la
vie quotidienne
[Musique]
rappelez-vous les 43 étudiants mexicaine
qui ont disparu l'armée et la police
sont impuissantes à endiguer la violence
si bien que les paysans ont décidé de
s'armer et entraîne même leurs enfants à
se défendre dans cet état il y à 13
compagnies canadiennes dont 3 exploite
des mines
les autres sont en exploration toutes
doivent composer avec ce climat de
violence la guerre contre le narcotrafic
a causé une fragmentation des cartels
qui ne pouvait plus vivre que du trafic
de drogue et d'armes
alors ils se sont tournés vers
l'extorsion et ils ont pris le contrôle
de territoires de grande activité
économique comme ceux où se trouvent les
minières nous l'appellerons xavier
autrefois un leader communautaire qui ne
mâchait pas ses mots ses vielles doit
aujourd'hui cacher son identité parce
que la vie est devenue plus dangereuse
que jamais quand tu dénonces la
disparition d'un membre de ta famille
les criminels sont immédiatement
informés par des officiers de police qui
travaille avec eux c'est pour ça que les
gens ne dénonce pas et que les opposants
aux minières ont marre
année après année
différents rapports dénonce la violence
la corruption l'extorsion le ministère
de l'environnement du mexique lui même
vient tout juste de dénoncer les
meurtres de gens qui s'opposent au
projet miné depuis leur arrivée dans
l'état de guerrero
les minières canadiennes ont été très
agressives envers la population
situation s'est empirée avec le temps
[Musique]
discutez de lien peut être obligé entre
des minières et le crime organisé est
très sensible le journaliste et ou
smooth enquêter comme résoudre et menacé
de mort depuis longtemps
il m'a indiqué le lieu du rendez-vous à
la dernière minute questions de sécurité
au mexique
c'est difficile pour un journaliste de
rester en vie ou d'espérer mourir vieux
ici un journaliste qui dérange
on peut le faire disparaître ou
l'exécutif avant son enquête
tiens dans ce livre le mexique à ciel
ouvert ou comment le bon minier a brisé
le pays le mexique connaît une nouvelle
colonisation comme celle que nous avons
vécue avec les espagnols il ya 500 ans
maintenant c'est avec les minières
canadiennes selon ses calculs les
minières canadiennes ont extrait en dix
ans deux fois plus d'or que les
espagnols en trois siècles de
colonisation social de détruire les sols
c'est une industrie salle l'industrie
minière du canada est une industrie
c'est immoral de ravager la terre
le fait que des groupes criminalisés
extorquer des minières au mexique ne
fait plus de doute en 2012
le procureur général du pays rapportait
que des compagnies devaient leur payer
jusqu'à 50 mille dollars par mois un
rapport international assure même que
certaines compagnies salirait
volontairement à ces groupes
pendant que nous prenons la route vers
le chiapas une autre région minière au
sud du pays
je ne peux pas oublier le paysan qui
chantait un corridor une chanson
populaire contre les minières
canadiennes
[Musique]
avec pierre qui nous sert toujours de
guides et de traducteurs nous roulions
verticaux musée l'eau
[Musique]
la personne n'a oublié qu'il y a dix ans
mariano à barca en opposant une mine
canadienne a été assassiné on veut
rencontrer sa famille lui qui est devenu
un héros local
symbole de la lutte contre lumière
le fils cadet mais nous visiter la ferme
est au fond du jardin
une jeep rouge attire mon attention je
parle mal l'espagnol
cela m'a pris quelques instants pour
saisir que c'est à bord de cette voiture
que son père a été abattu en plein jour
en ville
mon père ne pas été tués parce qu'ils le
volent et des gens et les états ou parce
qu'il faisait des choses illicites
il a été tué parce qu'il était contre
une société minière qui posait des
problèmes dans la vie
[Musique]
la vie a basculé ce jour de novembre sa
femme me renard n'a pas encore surmonté
la disparition violente de son mari avec
des photos des jours meilleurs
elle me raconte quel homme il était et
pourquoi il est intervenu à la demande
de riesener qui se plaignait de la
pollution causée par la minière black
file lorsqu'il a fait barrer la rue
principale où trafic des camions lourds
les menaces ont commencé avant d'être
tué il avait été arrêté et séquestré
pendant neuf jours parce qu'il avait
organisé une rencontre
je savais que c'était compliqué mais je
n'avais jamais pensé qu'il serait tué un
sous traitant de la compagnie black fire
a été reconnu coupable du meurtre
la famille a tenté d'obtenir réparation
auprès du canada
car elle considère que l'ambassade a
soutenu la minière aggraver les tensions
ce que réfute l'ambassade à la cour
fédérale canadienne la demande de la
famille a été rejetée mais le juge
soulignant que la famille aurait
souhaité que l'ambassade agissent
autrement
et peut-être que monsieur à barca
n'aurait pas été assassiné
finalement la mienne a été fermée pour
cause de pollution la violence envers
les opposants aux minières est palpable
les chiffres ont été avancés et si
l'université york enquêter sur des
instants expliquant 28 compagnies
canadiennes en amérique latine
concernant 44 décès et plus de 400
blessés
mais possible d'arriver à une conclusion
sur la responsabilité des minières pour
nous c'est clair que des gens ont été
assassinés parce qu'ils se sont opposés
aux minières c'est pô est là et mais
c'est très difficile de le prouver
devant les tribunaux mexicains
son rayon gustavo castro a vu la mort de
près il ya quatre ans lorsqu'il a été
atteint de deux balles alors que sa
collègue a été assassinée elle ce
survivant continue malgré tout à militer
et dénoncé la mine l as cannes a essayé
les minières canadiennes partent avec
l'or mais les entreprises n'apportent
pas avec elle le contaminées dans un
conteneur ni à vancouver ni à toronto
l'eau contaminée avec du cadmium du plan
du cyanure reste ici ont faim care
acquis depuis l'assassinât de mariano à
marca les gens ici se méfie des
canadiens oui sans aucun doute
il ya des bénévoles même des étudiants
glande l'europe à qui on n'a pas permis
d'entrer dans les communautés car on y
croyait canadienne
nous l'avons vécu au moment de partir de
chico musée l'eau des inconnus armés ont
menacé de nous enlever
moi et mon équipe parce qu'on était
canadien finalement rien ne nous est
arrivé
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'amazonie poumon de la planète
territoire mystique s'y rendre est une
aventure en soi
la rive du fleuve cac est à la porte
d'entrée de l'amazone ni colombienne
ça prenait un pilote expérimenté pour
atterrir ici
[Musique]
pendant deux jours nous allons woogie
dans l'immensité amazonienne il faut
aller jusqu'au brésil pour changer de
fleuve est arrivé aux territoires ddt et
makoun à grazailles raccourcis on
emprunte la pape auris qui serpente au
milieu de la forêt dense
la chute de la liberté et le premier
arrêt obligatoire
retenez bien ce lieu c'est le centre du
monde pour les autochtones d'ici c'est
aussi le centre d'une dispute une
minière canadienne caw seguros us
poursuit la colombie pour 22 milliards
de dollars
à l'entrée du territoire de jeunes
autochtones nous disent que l'endroit
est sacrée et que c'est pour ça qu'ils
ne veulent pas d'une minière ici nous
sommes les gardiens de ce territoire et
de la planète
c'est ici nous avons vu jour nous sommes
et nous sommes chez les matches on a ri
aussi mâconnais est devenu un patronyme
pour plusieurs
on traverse plusieurs villages qui
semble vide
les familles sont dans les jungles à
chasser ou accueillir encore nomades de
hier les autochtones se sédentarisent
peu à peu ici pas d'électricité les
femmes cuisinent sur des feux de bois
pas de radio pas de télé ni de téléphone
bien sûr depuis peu des panneaux
solaires alimentent une ampoule par
maison je voulais rencontrer les
autochtones qui au début était d'accord
avec l'exploitation de l'or ils nous
reçoivent dans la maloca nous nous
accrochons nous hamac la maloca tient à
la fois d'auberge d'église et d'hôtels
de ville
le chef albert ou à marcher le
territoire qu'ils nous dessine pour nous
livrer sa richesse et sa complexité
ils n'ont pas non
l'arrivée de la minière causé go à
diviser cette région amazonienne les uns
pour la mine les autres contre
étrangement la colombe et a accordé une
concession
alors qu'elle est en train de créer un
pacte national pour protéger ce
territoire une personne qui connaît bien
l'histoire et séraphine
il habite à quelques heures de bateau
séraphine et le grand leader spirituel
le rencontrer c'est comme parler avec le
dalaï lama de l'amazone ni colombienne
comment faire de l'argent
5000 $ comme premier paiement et ils
m'ont dit qu'ils allaient m'amener au
canada dans sa langue maternelle est le
relate sa rencontre avec les
représentants de kossi go s'il affirme
s'être sentie manipulée nous augmenter
l'offre à dîner le dollar j'ai perdu la
tête
j'ai oublié un tas que j'étais un
médecin traditionnel gardiez de ce
territoire
récemment élu chef dans une autre
communauté makoun à sonia se souvient
aussi de la visite des gens de côté
gauche lorsque ces gens sont venus ils
ont dit qu'ils allaient doter les
communautés d'écoles et de cliniques
médicales
donc les chefs ont accepté de travailler
avec la minière elle raconte que la
minière avait évité des autochtones du
canada et de l'alaska à venir les
rencontrer pour dit-elle les convaincre
que tout irait bien
ils ont dit que l'exploitation minière
était bonne et que cela n'affectait rien
et qu'ils avaient besoin que d'une
petite surface pour l'exploitation
minière
[Musique]
cette visite a eu l'effet inverse et a
été un point tournant pour nous ils
n'étaient pas de vrais autochtones
ils n'ont pas parlé de leur culture ni
de maluku surtout parlé de piloter un
hélicoptère et d'argent alors on a
commencé à se méfier parce que quelque
chose n'allait pas les chefs se sont
alors unis pour s'opposer à
l'exploitation de l'or sur leur
territoire
c'est un endroit sacré pour nous peuple
autochtone la chute de la liberté c'est
une porte pour laisser respirer le monde
ce site était l'endroit où la société
minière voulait exploiter et détruire
[Musique]
la chute de la liberté vous vous
souvenez un endroit sacré et inviolable
qui contient beaucoup d'or les
autochtones ici voilà terre comme une
entité un corps dont l'or et le coeur il
y a trop mines le monde
la planète est malade les atomes malade
et il ya des tremblements terre parce
qu'on extrait lors de la terre qui est
un être vivant
enfin on enlève une partie du coeur de
la terre
finalement la colombie a créé là un parc
national jusqu à me faire aux projets de
koffigoh la création de ce parc a été
contestée jusqu'en cour suprême pour
découvrir lors du procès que c'est
qu'aussi go qui tirait les ficelles
l'accompagné depuis sous enquête pour ce
comportement considéré illégal le biais
vous d'irrégularités était élevé
ces irrégularités ont été identifiés à
la cour suprême et l'ordre a été donné
d'enquêté comme chico ce qui se fait
actuellement
cela indique que les compagnies ont des
responsabilités non seulement envers
leurs actionnaires mais aussi auprès des
communautés du pays
[Musique]
francisco travaille avec les communautés
amazoniennes depuis des années et dirige
la fondation gaïa qui a participé à la
création du parc il y a beaucoup de
compagnies canadiennes qui ont commis
des irrégularités en colombie ce qui est
inacceptable c'est qu'au canada il y à
des règles strictes pour les minières
mais ici il n'y a aucun contrôle
les minières n'ont aucune responsabilité
écarté de sa concession d'or cocig aux
demandes à la colombie un dédommagement
22 milliards de dollars
même s'il n'y a jamais eu une mine c'est
ce que la compagnie considère avoir
perdu en profits qu'elle aurait pu
réaliser nous affirme le directeur de
l'exploitation 22 milliards s'est on
n'ose pont champlain
ils ont affirmé que l'état les parcs
nationaux
l'organisme gaia et les communautés
autochtones se sont ligués pour les
empêcher d'avoir accès à la région
c'est ridicule tu peux te l'idée pour
contrer une activité criminelle
camilo gomez et le directeur du bureau
juridique de l'état colombien
c'est une somme énorme mais c'est une
demande générale une exagération
aucun tribunal international
n'accepterait ça la réclamation sera
entendue devant un tribunal d'arbitrage
international
comment réagir et le canada le
gouvernement et l'état canadien si nous
voudrions exploiter une mine à ciel
ouvert au milieu d'un parc naturel
cela serait impossible joint au
téléphone le représentant de koffigoh
admet avoir financé l'opposition au parc
ce qu'il considère légal mais assure
n'avoir jamais en faire d'argent à
séraphine et qu'il est normal que la
compagnie soit dédommagée pour son
expropriation
[Musique]
de retour au canada je commence à avoir
des réponses en colombie britannique
j'ai retracé cet homme recruté par côté
gauche pour convaincre ses frères
d'amazonie de faire affaire avec elle
je suis un homme d'affaires j'ai un café
et un parc de maisons mobiles
je suis aussi impliqué dans plusieurs
autres activités comme les fournitures
médicales et l'industrie du cannabis il
a été le chef de cette communauté
gamigo si une entente avec une minière
d'or mais pourquoi at il accepté de se
rendre en amazonie je ne savais rien de
kossi go mais je savais qu'un groupe
d'autochtones voulez connaître notre
histoire notre expérience et comment
faire des affaires en utilisant nos
droits territoriaux aux commentaires de
séraphine à l'effet qu'il ne semblait
pas être vrais autochtones
nous sommes des gens d'affaires engagés
avec l'industrie mais le développement
n'est pas pour tous
koffigoh reçu ce qui est derrière cette
histoire l'amazone y est inscrite à la
bourse de vancouver même si son pdg est
américain et son actionnaire majoritaire
russie almaden mèneront ski domestique
est inscrite elle à la bourse de toronto
même si elle n'a pas de mines au canada
cela fait d'elle une minière canadienne
plus de 1000 entreprises minières sont
inscrites à la bourse de toronto ou de
vancouver la très grande majorité
n'opèrent qu'à l'étranger
elles sont toutefois l'image du canada
dans ces pays
elle apporte de l'eau au moulin
l'an dernier plus de 200 milliards de
dollars ont été transigées à la bourse
de toronto
ces deux fois le budget du québec se
sont mis sous les vôtres par nos fonds
de pension qui circulent ici une
sociologue québécoise qui vit en
colombie depuis huit ans à étudier la
bourse et les minières il ya beaucoup de
spéculations c'est à dire que la plupart
du temps on va voir un projet minier on
va obtenir les on va obtenir les
concessions mais ensuite tout ça sert
simplement à dire à la bourse de toronto
regardez on a trouvé des réserves plus
grande donc on vend quoi des actions on
vend pas de l'or on vend des actions ont
fait monter des actions fait de la
spéculation au feu de l'argent là dessus
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui attire ces
entreprises ici d'abord notre tous des
positions pour les minières est plus
faible que dans la plupart des autres
pays développés et depuis le
gouvernement a un peu les ambassades ont
pour mission d'aider les entreprises
minières
c'est nous les canadiens qui finançons
en fait cette grande entreprise mondiale
des miliaires au nom du canada qui vont
recevoir une à un service d'assurance
politique par edc canada qui vont
recevoir des services diplomatiques par
nos ambassades
[Musique]
parlant de tribunaux j'ai découvert le
monde de l'arbitrage international
un monde invisible aux yeux du commun
des mortels des tribunaux partout dans
le monde où des avocats de grands
bureaux arbitre poursuite de compagnie
qui s'estiment lésés par une décision
gouvernementale
j'ai rencontré yves fortier ancien
diplomate et arbitre depuis 25 ans pour
comprendre le fonctionnement de cette
justice supranationale comme comme en
cours nous recevons des plaidoiries
d'aidé mémoire des déclarations de
témoins chaque parti est représenté par
avocat se présente devant notre tribunal
habituellement ce sont les tribunaux
comprenant trois personnes président est
lui qu arbitre et on analyse la preuve
on délibère et on rentre décision il n'y
a pas d'appel possible et le tribunal
n'est pas ouvert au public
l'audience devant un tribunal arbitral
les procédures sont confidentielles oui
ça c'est vrai les représentants des
partis témoignent devant le tribunal et
la décision est rendue publique le
système efficace et rapide soutient yves
fortier
mais tout le monde ne voit pas les
choses du même oeil en 2015 en belgique
des milliers de personnes se sont
opposées à l'inclusion des tribunaux
dans l'accord de libre-échange avec le
canada à toronto
le vice recteur de l'école de droit à
l'université york qui a étudié le
système d'arbitrage international expose
ses critiques
c'est un mécanisme unilatéral seulement
les investisseurs peuvent poursuivre les
pays mais pas l'inversé
c'est un aspect très controversé de ce
système car il donne des pouvoirs
extraordinaires à des compagnies déjà
puissante et riche
pourquoi leur donner ces puissantes
protection internationale de plus les
décisions de ces tribunaux met de la
pression sur les gouvernements pour
modifier leur politique car le
gouvernement que vous avez élu ne sera
plus à même de remplir ses promesses
devant la menace de réclamations des
investisseurs étrangers
cette menace pu le faire reculer ils ne
vous le dira même pas comment savoir si
cette menace n'a pas été un facteur
important dans la décision du
gouvernement fédéral d'acheter le lait
odieux qu'il y a quelques années en
achetant le lie au duc
il ne risque plus d'être poursuivis par
des investisseurs étrangers
il ne va pas se poursuivre
parmi les pays développés le canada est
le plus poursuivi surtout par des
compagnies américaines en vertu de
l'alena
vous vous souvenez lorsque le québec à
limiter l'exploitation du gaz sous le
fleuve saint-laurent et bien
l'américaine longue panne ressources
qu'ils détenaient des permis de
recherche poursuit actuellement le
canada pour 321 millions de dollars
les sommes en jeu sont importantes car
les réclamations englobe les profits
anticipés sur des amis et pour finir
ottawa pour rencontrer le député qui
s'est attiré les foudres de l'industrie
lorsqu'il a présenté une loi pour mettre
au pas les compagnies canadiennes à
l'étranger
soudainement les minières et surtout
leurs lobbyistes qui ont vu une
véritable menace à leur façon de faire
ils ont envahi le plancher fois vu la
loi pour obliger les minières à
respecter les standards canadiens en
matière d'environnement et de droits
humains à l'étranger a été battu de peu
je me considère un libéral de droite
je crois que l'économie doit être
développée mais il y a des choses qu'on
ne peut pas faire
tiendra deux il tiendra on ne peut pas
détruire l'environnement ou violer les
droits humains juste pour faire de
l'argent et non pas du tout
cela fait 15 ans qu'au parlement au
discute d'encadrer les compagnies et les
rendre responsables de leur comportement
en 2015
trudeau a promis un ombudsman un chine
garde contre les abus commis par des
compagnies à l'étranger
ottawa nous dit que la personne a
finalement été choisi et sera en mesure
de recevoir des plaintes concernant une
atteinte aux droits de la personne et
pourtant le comportement des minières
canadiennes est constamment l'ordre du
jour lors de rencontres avec les
représentants de pays étrangers
pourquoi cette résistance de la part de
l'industrie minière
la peur de perdre en compétitivité c'est
un argument qui peut plaire mais de
l'autre côté le dommage à la marque de
la compagnie est à l'image du canada est
immense
on ne s'en rendait peut-être pas compte
mais l'image du pays s'est détériorée à
cause du comportement de certaines
minières canadiennes à l'étranger
j'aurais traverser l'amérique pour boire
et vous montrer les pratiques de
certaines de ses compagnies et la
dynamique qui se crée dans des états où
la corruption sévit
finalement c'est peut-être ici à ottawa
que réside le début de la solution
obligée non minières à faire des
affaires d'or tout en respectant les
standards canadiens
[Musique]
non